my name is vincent moser
i'm a physician trained in internal
medicine and board certified in internal
medicine
i joined mcgill last year and the
main date i have is to build up a
genomics medicine program
at mcgill within the framework of the
canada excellence research chair
in genomic medicine my background
apart from being an internist a
clinician is i've been training
in genetics in pharmacology and
cardiovascular diseases
i've spent 10 years in industry i've
been back to switzerland where i come
from
to lead large efforts in laboratory
medicine
and here i am now in montreal
what i'm planning to do today is first
thank the organizers for giving me the
chance to present
this biobank which we believe is an
important asset
for quebec and also for the kovid19
overall research community
it is also an asset which could be very
valuable and will benefit from
ai investigations the second thing i
will do is
present to you this construction
if you don't mind i will spend 15
minutes also presenting that
and then we have times for questions and
i will read
the chat at that time so i'm not
encouraging you to use the chat right
now because i will
not read it during my presentation
but then after completion of my
presentation i'm happy to
have a look at the chat and identify
questions
okay i'm starting
this slide shows on the x-axis the time
days and on the y-axis the number of
people who were hospitalized for coving
infection
in the regular worlds in orange and in
the icus
in burgundy the big arrow
here illustrates these dates when
i met the head this
head scientist of the province remy
kirion
and carol jaber the head of the form of
research
on something quebec and daniel coder the
head of genome quebec
we had this discussion it was not around
kobe but of course
covet came up we were 19th of nov march
and they said okay we need to put in
place on infrastructure we don't have
yet any cases of patients
hospitalized in the province but we
anticipate that tsunami will come
and we need to get ready and they gave
essentially me the mandate
to build up a structure whereby
researchers
in covet would have the necessary
samples and data
to do their research
the mission we were given was to ensure
that scientists have access to the
biological materials and data
which would be needed for their research
efforts
specifically on the determinants of copy
19 susceptibility that means why do some
people develop covenant some others not
severity and outcome and in that way
we wanted to respond effectively to the
public health challenges
which was posed by the pandemic and of
course use
a sound scientific basis and
most importantly as well an appropriate
ethical
and legal framework
this slide here shows you the milestones
again 19th of march we received the
mandate
10 days later we have a task force in
place so
with the help of cajon
we put up a group of 12 people
each with specific expertise
in genomics icu
clinics virology vaccinology
immunology law ethics
communication finance and
we work extremely hard for 30 days to
first
identify what are the questions we want
to enable what is the design of the bio
bank we need to put in place
to help our researchers address this
question
submit the filing
for ethics approval and we did that in
10 days
so that one day later
we could start the recruitment of the
first patient here at the jewish general
hospital
we could essentially surf on this first
wave
so that within two months we had already
a thousand patients
in public health agency of canada which
was
sensitive to the fact that quebec in
montreal in particular was very badly
hit by the virus
gave us additional funding to
expand our program we did the first
genetic analysis on the first 400
samples already in july
and we had the genome well association
studied data
available for researchers by mid of jula
i just want here to list the people who
have been working extremely hard to make
it happen
i'm sharing this task force we have here
the name of the people their affiliation
uh we have now met 62 times
over the past months for an hour and a
half
always by virtual meetings have
never met half of these people just by
by uh by zoom
and we worked extremely hard together
we have put as well the governing
structure
this is not exciting but this is
important
within the framework of our discussion
today there is a steering committee here
which i'm chairing at the director
we have the governance committee which
is advised
by an international scientific advisory
board which is chaired by antoine flower
from geneva importantly enough
as well in our discussion today
for accessing data in samples from the
biobank we have
a data and sample sorry for the s
access committee here which is linked to
a
separate entity
the vision is shown here
at the bottom you can see 11 hospitals
so it's a province wide
federated decentralized infrastructure
each hospital feeding data and samples
into the biobank
we managed to have 11 institutions from
five universities
signing the same inter-institutional
agreement that was already by itself a
total force
we are now collecting same present data
from these hospitals
and the idea here is to perform an
in-depth multi-ohmic
analysis on the samples which are being
collected here
keep that in mind as well when you're
thinking about ai usage
for exploring this data set
so we're working with a initiative
called cancogen to access
this genome virus data we're working
with conchogen as well
to have access to whole genome
sequencing data from the host we're
talking here about
three billion base pairs for each
individual
we're working with the shim here to get
deep serology analysis and also for
transcriptomics that means analysis of
the gene
expression in the white blood cells
collected from the blood
to see expression of genes also
importantly
genes involved in immunology and we are
doing also
proteomic analysis in this particular
case we have a company called somalogic
which is performing a test called some
scan whereby
we are they are for us measuring
5 000 different samples in the
blood that we have shipped to them
what we're expecting from this data set
is to better understand
mechanism of propagation individual
susceptibility to diseases
mechanisms of disease protection but
also build up a cohort that we will be
following
prospectively and at the end of the day
really what will count
is how much these data set
made available for the research
community will
help our stakeholders and public
agencies
for designing the exit strategy optimal
surveillance
hopefully participate to discovery of
new drugs in back seats
but also a patient called
the design is extremely simple it's
shown here
initially we focus on severe cases that
means
people who have been hospitalized for
suspicion
of covered disease
we are collecting data at admission day
zero
then prospectively for those who stay in
the hospital
at day 2 7 14 30
and also past discharge up to
24 months we are also now starting to
collect patients who have not been
hospitalized
that means moderately or mildly affected
individuals a unique feature
of this biobank is that we are
collecting controls as well which are
critical for
any type of of biomedical trials
these people are controls that means
they are have a suspicion of being
coveted infected yet
pci is telling us that they do not have
source to
go to source code to infection
this is the network of the hospitals
which we are working with in the five
universities
of course again i need to acknowledge
here the very
good will of all these people we have 11
lawyers
talking to each other to come up with an
agreement that makes everybody more or
less happy
to the recruitment process is standard
we are collecting the consent of the
patients which is particularly
complicated
when you're dealing with highly
infectious
people same thing for the handling and
collection of biological symptoms this
is infectious material
we need to be very careful about
protecting the health of
the working
collaborators in the data collection
extensive clinical data
also access to medical records
laboratory data
and so that's a big body of data which
is being made up and will be made
available to researchers
we're talking here about probably 300
people
with a variety of different professional
expertise
and who have essentially rolled up their
sleeves to make it happen
clinical research nursing care computer
laboratories administration
legal ethics and technical services
working together to make it happen
as per the end of the wave one
we had 1200 participants now we have
1500 participants who have been
recruited
in this study and we are in the process
of doing the initial analysis
on them and they can available as i said
before
we have whole genome data for
500 people and this data will be made
available very soon actually it's on the
website
i just want here because we're talking
also
use of ai and big data for
drug discovery and development to show
you this particular slide
it is a project run by dr brent richards
at the jewish general hospital
and the idea here is to use a particular
[Music]
bioinformatic complex approach called
mendelian randomization
to identify new drug targets for carbon
19 and what brent is this team
came up with is by combining very big
data sets from the uk biobank and other
data sets
and genome-wide association study for
covid come up here with
four different molecules
circulating proteins which are closely
and very significantly associated with
uh coveted susceptibility severity
and hospitalization and they may
represent
potential drugs for repositioning for
covet
indication
so what are the next steps for us of
course we want to continue the
recruitment of severe patients
and also accelerate our recruitments of
outpatients so far we have 250 people
outpatients we want to follow these
individuals longitudinally provide data
and samples for researchers
link this data with other national in
international initiatives
of course disseminate the knowledge
developed to public health
authorities in the canadian public and
develop interfaces with the scientific
inpatient community
in particular through the website which
is
shown here so
on this website there are also
conditions and
ways by which researchers can access
the the data so i'm done
with my presentation
and i don't know if there are any
questions
uh we have a question here about jacqui
what kinds of data points are we
collecting for the patients
so we are collecting serially
data in samples for
the patients who are hospitalized
this is the study design
now we do not have
every time points for every patient
because it's very complicated
we have for a certain fraction of
patients
zero to seven we are starting as well to
have these data sets after discharged
we are also facing difficulties in the
sense
that due to the pandemic and the
sanitary measures it's
very hard to go back to people who
convince them to come back to the
hospital
for blood draws so we're designing now
new ways to get these data in samples
that's one thing the second thing is
that
there are lots of patients who are
essentially saying
we've been sick it was a very severe flu
sometimes we've been
in the icu but it's over we don't want
to talk about it anymore so
we have to put in ways as well um
modes for essentially keeping these
people in reduced saturation
our website will give precisely the
number of people who have been
collected at different time points
jackie does it answer your question
uh stephanie stephanie you're asking
will we be able to study long-term
effects of kobe that we see in some
patients
the answer is yes we are planning to
and actually we have funding as well to
follow up these patients
up to 24 months i think the question is
absolutely essential i can just refer to
some preliminary data which i have seen
from the uk
a program called see more whereby they
have
prospectively followed patients in
controls actually
and they show using imaging and other
quality of life measurements that indeed
covered in 19 infected patients at least
when they were reassessed after two or
three months have a higher
probability of having anxiety depression
but also
multi-organ inflammation so it's a very
good point
and we will do our best to get as many
parts as patients as possible we were
lucky
because we could capture this first wave
not that many hospitals could capture
first-wave patients because they were so
busy
in doing clinical care
you are asking the question how does the
information exchange work across the
provinces and internationally
this is also a really important point so
here we are committed to open science
firstly
and so the data and the same sorry the
data
and the simple cs that we are collecting
are being made available
to the entire research community so we
have this data and access
committee which has as a limit to make
sure
that these data and samples are made
available
the consent and that's really critical
allows for sharing of the data
for researchers including industry
internationally as well as long as the
researchers adhere
to the standards that we
we require now we have
already started to share the g-was data
the genome-wide association studied data
and we are part of this genomic host
initiative and so we are already
contributing data
to these efforts
jacqui is asking for a comment on my
response
clinical data so the clinical data are
part of the data which are being made
available to the research community
and we are in the process
of putting in place the it
infrastructure with mikhail chasse
at the and with the genome center
guillaume
book so that this data is properly
packaged
for sharing while protecting
the identity and avoiding
re-identification
izaba suspect isabel is asking
about the correlation between [ __ ] blood
group and susceptibility to
kobe 19 i can elaborate
i'm not sure i have the response but
what seems to happen is that
this signal with the [ __ ] blood group
maybe and i'm saying really maybe be
careful maybe an artifact
it may be due to the fact that
this new england paper was based on data
generated in italy and spain mostly and
the controls
where people from blood banks and we
know that people who are doing
donating blood at the blood banks are
not representative of the general
population because they are also asked
to
donate blood based on specific blood
groups so
it is possible that we may have an
artifact
that's also an incentive for us to
recruit and collect
data and samples from our proper control
source curve to negative populations
from what i have seen in the recent
metadata from large consortium
the [ __ ] group same signal
seem to vanish stefan
stefan to demand what more immediate use
will be made of the biobank by ai or
digital projects
and approaches
there are a series of things that we
could do with
a uh directly with our connections
the biobank and for instance mila and
we have already been discussing with you
stefan and
with uh other people
at the the mila so
using this data set and see how ai can
be used essentially to
exploit it and maybe identify gems
as well and tools hidden in these
mountains and address some specific
questions we're also working with
closely with miguel chasse miguel
has a cihr grant for using ai
in collaborations with milai and others
on
copy the data set finally as i said the
data
is being will be made available for
investigations around the world who can
use essentially their tools
including ais to explore this data set
i don't know if there are any other
questions i think there is one
from netanyahu
yes uh nathaniel you referred here to a
paper published by zolor casanova in
this team
in this in the science issue around
three weeks ago now and what uh jean
lauren casanova
in this group did was investigate using
sequencing
the 13 genes involved in the in the
interferon pathway
and you're right they identified some
mutations which seem to predispose
to disease commit severity
have we found the same i cannot answer
this question yet
because we are just now q
seeing the latest uh
whole genome sequencing data but we will
certainly look at that
what we have done though in my group
and is look if
some of these mutations they are rare
there are rare
functional mutations if these mutations
are present
in excess in the quebec french canadian
population because this french canadian
population has a founder effect and so
some variants are over represented
what we have found and that's the work
that cloud behave has done in my group
is that indeed some of the variants
identified by general casanova and his
team are overrepresented
in our quebec population and we need to
explore that further
if there are people interested in this
work
on rare functional variants and how we
want to exploit them
for supporting drug discovery and
development i'm actually giving
a second talk you know now writing is at
350. that's what i have presented here
is my sort of
moonlighting job and i have a day job
which is this canada excellence research
chair in genomic medicine which i'm
presenting
a bit later so i guess
if there are no more questions i would
like
to thank you all 23 attendees it's great
i'm very glad i had the chance to
present
this work and i certainly look forward
to having this wealth of data
including multi-omics data that will be
available for research
and for ai exploration so
i will stay in touch certainly with mila
i will stay in touch as well
with industry because this
biobank also serves as a reservoir of
patients for trials
and we can now also use ai in other
markers including genomics to
potentially select
patients for trials and deep phenotyping
so thank you very much to all and it was
a pleasure to share that with you bye
you